oh very special guest congratulations
Fabby yeah congratulations Fabiana I
have hero of the day today favano
yesterday you were telling me two points
I'm fighting only for the second place
and here we go now you you won the
tournament how did it happen with a lot
of luck absolutely no I mean last two
games were terrible but before that I
think I won some very important games
three in a row uh these were really
important and okay last game I was just
incredibly lucky against Max can I say I
mean he uh he was winning okay it was
kind of equal but unpleasant for me for
a long time and then he he played rookie
too but he kind of like I think dropped
it for a second and then he realized
that and then he picked it back up and
then he I don't know I'm not 100% sure
if he dropped it but he said he did so
of course other had to play a rookie to
after that well rookie for and he's two
pawns up I mean not I wouldn't resign
yet but yeah I'd probably lose this of
course I
like this moment Rook A3 is very simple
like many you realized it after no I
realize it
now no many many regrettable moments in
the last two games um but overall yeah
it it worked out so what this Victory I
mean you have won so many tournaments
but what particular victory means for
you this one this one is really
important because also for the grand
chest tour it's uh it's I don't know if
I'm like almost securing first place in
Grand chest with this but it's very
close to securing I think uh so this one
was really important because I really
wanted to to win grandest tour this year
and I don't know if I'm have yet or
anything but it's definitely a big step
towards that and um also I've never won
rapid and Blitz uh Grand chest Tour
event it's the first time so I won some
like Blitz and Rapid events but never in
the grand chest tour so this is but the
thing is I've had better tournaments
than here than I've done here like I
remember one time in Warsaw we played a
tournament and I think I finished 24
points and I got fourth place so so here
I finished like 21 points and I got
first place so it depends on what how
your opponents are also playing right
yeah this is why I'm lucky but that's
what it's better to be lucky and bad
than unlucky and good that's the thing
you're probably meaning this previous
game like how did you feel going to the
last round after losing against rare
ropes and this absolutely crazy position
yeah yeah it was a draw on the end I
believe but I had already kind of made
it difficult um but I ran out of time in
a drawn position I I believe it was a
draw at least uh but I was down a full
piece at some like literally full piece
of maybe I had one Pawn for it or
something so of course this was a a bad
game I think I have to say I'm very
proud of my games against Yan against um
against alira and against Anish I think
those three games I'm I'm very proud of
the level I show in those games yeah so
I mean it was very tiring tournament
five days but it's not over in two days
we're going to have singfield cup what
are you going to do between during those
two days how are you going to celebrate
oh celebrate well I'll try try to
celebrate tonight um it's of course a
very good feeling I mean I couldn't have
hoped for better like if you told me
yesterday that I would even be fighting
for first I wouldn't believe you because
two points and Maxim I thought would be
in very good shape today but um but he
wasn't in his best shape and yeah so
this is of course a dream that I
actually managed to win this tournament
it's like completely unexpected and now
we play classical chess so it's a bit
more stable let's say you know usually
less well always there's less action
still you know it's I hope to play well
but but at least I won't have so many
emotional ups and downs like here
exactly I mean by the way I was still
believing that you can win the
tournament as well as t s who is the one
of the commentators here and we won
lunch with yaser because of that so
thank you fa it was really amazing also
lunch that's a good point yes sir are
you inviting
also it's
commentator only commentators but in any
in any case I mean five is such a great
result I mean such a great tournament
thanks so much for this drama for
everything what happened today even for
the fact that you lost this previous in
the previous round it was really amazing
to see all this thank you and all the
best of luck for you simple definitely
to you guys thank you Anastasia